dea
今から日本語の講座を行えます
皆さんこんばんは同源です8この怖いだと判るかなと思いますがじつは3週間ぐらい前
からかなりひどい咳が続いています
で新しい動画を作るたびにそれが悪化してしまう
で今回の動画の朗読を
square enix で翻訳の仕事をしている友達のクリス4にお願いしてみまし
た
なので普段とちょっと違う感じになるかなと思いますがご了承ください
どうしてもいつもと同じように皆さんのところに新しい動画を届けたかったですそれで
はよろしくお願いしますクリス
日本に住んだことがないけど日本で a を教えたい
q 外国人がたくさんいる
彼らの多くは大学を卒業したあとで実際に日本に来ていろんな先生になる
そして23年したらまた自分のクールに帰ってしまう
今日はこの現象について話したいと思う
日本に住んだことがないといる日本でエールを教えたい
まずはこの表現を分析してみろ
英語圏以外の国であれば4先生になれますそれほど難しいことではない
この理屈から考えると日本に住んで英語を教えたいって言うような人たちは日本に
こだわっていることがわかる
アニメが好きだったり格闘技が好きだったり日本女性や好きだったりしてとにかく彼ら
は日本のどこかが好きなはずだ
それを自分の家族と友達を捨てて生まれて育った場所を離れてもいいぐらい強い情熱で
ある
簡潔に言うと日本に住んだことがないけど日本でエールを教えたいっていうような人は
大倉
日本ビーチである
まあ多くかソードアートオンラインのお得だと言った方が正確だろうけど
ただし国連申し上げたいのは彼らが日本ビーチになるのは日本に来る前である
かなりの想像力が働いているわけだ
秋葉原のパソコンさや牛や恋人との題はレートなど日本に引っ越す前はこのような
楽しいをものを創造する
想像して欠点がない日本を魂の中で含ませるのだメイド喫茶のオムライスからもらった
食中毒等横浜での恋人喧嘩などは想像しない
川崎駅から歩いて15分もかかるのに
月9万円もする狭いアパートでのゴキブリ戦争は誰も想像しない
だからいわゆる日本びいきは実際に日本に来たらガッカリしてやがて自分の国に帰って
しまうと多くの人理由が僕はこれは実は違うと思う
sa 用のコスプレイしか考えていないアニメオタクは確かにゴキブリ戦争を予想し
ないが
sa ようなコスぺーしか海外てないアニメオタクは充実した健康保険制度も安くて
美味しいほっともっとも予想しない
つまり予期せぬ失望ももちろんあるが予期せぬ感動もある
10回も行ったら原宿コスプレの神先生が多少してるかもしれないが急に悪いこと
ばかり起こるわけではない
だったらなぜみんな自分の国に帰ってしまうのか
個人的な意見だが答えは英語を教えるにあると思う
日本びいきたちの夢は日本にすることであり英語を教えることではないはずだ
しかしどうしても日本に住みたい人たちにとっては仕事を犠牲にするのが難しいさん
だけではない
日本に勧めるなら喜んで色をしていると体が信じるわけだ
残念ながらみんな sa 様のお宅でありえ営業の文房だけではない
だからそれを3年間毎日9時から5時までずーっとを敷いていたらさすがの姉御オタク
も疲れてくる
考え方が悲観的になり客観的に見て
安木てホイ c ほっともっとさえも上げて嫌いな日本へと変化してしまう
彼らは日本ではなく日本で送っている自分の生活が嫌になってしまう
なにしろ彼らの本当の夢は日本を楽しむことであり給料が低い英語の先生になることで
はない
ということでここで日本で栄養士会たい視聴者たちに一つの上限をしたいと思う
日本できたことがなければ初めて大日した時は大きく感動するだろう
しかし生活していると日本がもう今日から自分が住んでいる国に変わっていく
その時に大事になってくるのは毎日の9時から5時までの間である
あなたは趣味な色の音声学の本を読むことでバンコクでもいいからとにかく英語を教え
たいと思うなら
気持ちよく日本で英語を教えられるだろう
しかしあなたの首位がコースプレーをして写真を撮ることであればあなたは栄養の先生
ではなく
コスプレイも奴隷になるべきだ
そのため写真集の作り方やポーズの取り方ならぬ
戻れに必要な知識と能力を身につけるべきだ
日本に住んだことがないけど日本で a を教えたいという外国人にとあなたは一生
来日することができなかったらどのような仕事を目指す
その仕事こそ日本ですべきだそしてそれが実現できるように今から必要な資格などを
取得すべきだ
でないといくらキリトの格好をするのが好きだとしてもそれを毎日自分が楽しめるもの
にはできないしそれどころかずっと同じセリフを繰り返す英会話オンラインの mpc
になってしまうだけだブー
ni